for nine seasons Brian Bumgardner was an
integral member of the stellar comedic
ensemble of the American version of the
office Baumgartner played Kevin Malone
one of Dunder Mifflin's accountants who
was generally regarded as pretty much
the dumbest guy in the office unlike
some of his former cast mates who went
on to star in their own shows who are
appear in blockbuster movies Bumgardner
has kept a lower profile since the
office went off the air here's a look at
what he's been up to both on screen and
off crash pilots in the middle of the
final season of the office in 2013
Baumgartner already had an eye toward
what he'd be working on next a new
comedy series for ABC like the office it
was planned as a single-camera comedy
set in a workplace conceived by office
executive producer Greg Daniels and late
Parks and Recreation writer and producer
Harris whittles Baumgartner was going to
play Norman a middle manager at an
airline trying to turn his life around
unfortunately ABC pulled the plug in the
series before a pilot was shot
reportedly because executives weren't
happy with the writing Baumgartner moved
from one disappointing pilot process
into another the next year when he
landed a role in Amazon's maker Shack
agency between friendly pilot was about
a group of kids with a knack for
inventing who builds stuff to get their
classmates out of jams Baumgartner was
cast as the kids principal Amazon plays
the pilot online for viewing by the
general public but makers Shack agency
wasn't approved for a season long run
guest roles galore Baumgartner was a
workaday actor before he landed a series
regular spot on the office and since the
show ended he's returned to being a busy
character actor on TV since 2013 he's
landed more than a dozen guest roles
including playing a pedophile and
law-and-order a Special Victims Unit an
elapsed a a sponsor on the FX drama the
bridge he's also done a few commercial
spots including teaming up with a
barbershop quartet for Microsoft
Baumgartner has also popped up in
several small films including 2016's
ordinary world a comedy about an aging
punk rockers starring Billy Joe
Armstrong of Green Day if there is any
damage done to that hotel room
we will prosecute me family time with
the rigorous shooting schedule of a
Network sitcom behind him baumgartner's
had more time to focus on his personal
life in April 2014 he tied the knot with
his longtime partner Celeste Eccleston
the wedding went down in the backyard of
Baumgartner's Los Angeles home and also
reportedly served as a mini office
reunion about a year later Baumgartner
and åkesson welcomed a baby girl
Bumgardner joked on Instagram that his
daughter looks forward to catching up on
all the old episodes of The Office once
her eyes adjust to life teatime
Bumgardner got really into golf in his
theater days as a way to decompress
while traveling and performing a
grueling eight shows a week scheduled
Bumgardner told The Daily Beast that
golf was a great way to get outside and
now he's a regular on the celebrity golf
tournament circuit Duffing it up in the
drew brees celebrity championship and
the American Century championship in
2007 Golf Digest ranked Baumgartner at
number 49 on its list of Hollywood's top
100 golfers anybody can compete at any
level and it's about that competing with
yourself it's always different every day
is different every course is different
company man Baumgartner is a big sports
fan and he's a veteran of entertainment
history he combined the two and started
his own media company threebees
entertainment a reference to his full
name
Brian Bruce Baumgartner among the
company's projects are an NBC Sports
feature called golf therapy life lessons
in the pursuit of par and a scripted
comedy for college humor called turtle
race poker face casino night the offices
second season finale revealed a
surprising truth about Kevin Malone I
won the 2002 $2,500 no-limit deuce to
seven draw tournament at the World
Series of Poker in Vegas so yeah
I'm pretty good at poker while
Baumgartner isn't a poker champion like
his character he is an avid player often
anting up for celebrity and charity
tournaments he told poker news in 2013
that he did so well at one of those
fundraisers he won a seat the actual
world series of poker unfortunately life
did not quite imitate art Bumgardner had
to give up his seat to shoot the show I
suck thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]